comment s'est passé l'été cou super
comme tu peux le voir petite visite de
contrôle avant l'hivernage ce
particulier s'est jeté à l'eau il y a 2
ans maintenant mais pour creuser sa
piscine il ne s'attendait pas à être
submergé par toutes ses démarches il y
avait des un tas de documents à remplir
des photos àaires plein de choses à
faire que j'ai transmis que j'ai
transmis à la mairie après la mairie
donc de valerois le rio m'a bien
aiguillé m'a bien aidé donc voilà il y
avait un lapse de temps avant de
commencer les travaux pour être en
conformité et et après ça suivi son
cours quoi et heureusement le pisciniste
était là aussi pour le guider on aide le
client on suit le chantier mais on fait
on l'aide aussi dans les démarches
administratives que ce soit la demande
préalable de travaux et après le conseil
évidemment de la déclarer aux impôts ce
qui ce qui est normal et ce qui doit
être fait par tout le monde tout le
monde enfin pas vraiment c'est tombé du
ciel en haute zone on a découvert 459
piscines non déclarées grâce à ICAD ce
nouvel outil des finances publiques qui
permet de comparer les cartes aériennes
de l'hygienne l'Institut géographique
national au cadastre les différences
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle
l'objectif de de l'intelligence
artificielle est d'aller vérifier si la
piscine qui figure sur la photo a fait
l'objet d'un assugétissement à la taxe
foncière si elle est évaluée dans la
documentation cadastrale tester l'en
passé dans neuf départements le
dispositif a été étendu cette année à
toute la France pas pour piéger les
fraudeurs mais pour rétablir dit-on la
justice fiscale je pense qu'il y a des
personnes qui n'avaient pas conscience
qu'ell devaient déclarer le leur piscine
donc je me permettrai pas de les
qualifier de de trich en tout cas
effectivement il y avait un taux de
défaillance qui n'est pas négligeable
7,6 % de de défaillance constaté sur sur
un département comme la haute zone ça
nous met je dirais un petit peu audessus
de la moyenne nationale de ce qu'on a
constaté durant l'expérimentation de ce
nouvel outil les communes deone vont
surtout pouvoir récupérer 84000 €
d'impôts qui leur échappa chaque année
vousziv sur